The fundamental point that I
want to make today is that,
well, economic theory
describes, people has managing,
they're maximizing their own utility
and subject to constraints. Uh,
most people have a lot
of trouble doing that,
particularly as regards
investing in financial markets.
Most people are confused and,
uh, find it just very difficult.
So,
um,
we have an industry of people who
help people with their investments,
uh, and we moreover have a
whole array of regulations,
uh,
regulating the industry of people who
help others with their investments.
The problem is that most people are
not that good at dealing in financial
markets. They're mysterious,
they're difficult. And Moreover, uh,
there's a tendency of psychological
biases that cause people to get into
mistakes.
Uh,
we talked about overconfidence that
most people think they're smarter than
others,
and it seems like people can easily get
overconfident about their
ability to beat the market. Uh,
and what naturally
happens if not regulated,
is that there will be others who will
victimize and exploit these people.
So the classic story is some
kind of stockbroker who,
uh, promises to make
great wealth for you, uh,
by trading your portfolio.
Uh, and, uh, in fact, uh,
doesn't really know anything.
The guy is just a showman
who is just pretending.
Uh,
there was a 1940s book called
where are the customers yachts,
which, uh, it was a best selling book.
The title refers to the
fact that stockbrokers give
the impression that oh idea
with a very wealthy,
successful crowd of people and you are
now one of the chosen people that I'm
managing for.
And so some stockbrokers will
pretend to be very wealthy,
create the appearance of that,
like are associated with the rich people.
And it draws people in.
But in fact,
the customers often don't do very well
because the stockbroker make churn,
their portfolio keep coming up with new
trades and the broker is making money
from commissions and, um, uh,
that's the kind of problem that arises.
So as a result,
a lot of people recognize the
importance of giving help to people.
Uh, and so that's what we're talking
about. I want to talk mostly about,
uh,
portfolio managers,
uh, but I first talk about, uh,
financial advisors,
uh,
and also financial planners.
Um,
and then I'll move to a fiduciaries
or institutional investors.
Uh,
so we do not live in a world where people
freely do business as they would like.
The financial world is especially
heavily regulated. Okay.
So the first thing is
financial advisor. Uh, again,
most people don't know
about these markets.
They need someone to give them advice.
So people set themselves up
as financial advisers. Um,
and uh, in most countries, these are
heavily regulated by the government, uh,
in the United States. Now what does
that, what does a financial advisor,
I should define that for you?
It's someone who gives advice about
investments for some kind of fee or
commission. All right? Uh,
it excludes lawyers,
bankers,
insurance salesmen,
reporters for newspapers,
professors. Even though these people
may all give financial advice,
it's not considered as part of law
to be a central to what they do.
And so there are excluded from the
definition of financial advisor.
Uh,
it also excludes broker dealers.
If someone presents himself
or herself just as a broker,
that's someone you can call up and say,
I want to buy a hundred
shares of GM or whatever.
And the person does the deal,
does the trade for you.
That is also not a financial advisor.
Even if that person,
uh,
occasionally dispenses advice,
it's only incidental to the business.
Financial advisers includes people who
present themselves as offering advice to
individuals and also includes analysts.
So,
uh,
these are regulated and there's something
called the National Securities Markets
Improvement Act of 1996.
National Securities Market Improvement
Act says that all financial advisors with
less than 25 million under
management must regulate,
must register with the state regulator.
And if it's greater than 30 million,
they must register with the SCC in
Washington Securities and Exchange
Commission. If it's between,
they can choose either.
Uh, so they're all regulated.
Okay. And, uh, the, uh,
government,
uh,
wants to be sure that
financial advisors are, uh,
no, uh, what good practice is.
And so that means they have to take an
exam and the exam is administered by a,
what's called Finra should
know. Um, that is, uh, was it,
uh, financial institutions
regulatory authority,
formerly called an ASD.
See how this is getting complicated.
And a s D is National Association
of securities dealers.
And they started the
Nasdaq Stock Market index,
which you hear about all the time.
Nasdaq is Nisd automation,
automated quotation system,
but NISD merged with the New York Stock
Exchange Regulatory Authority last year.
And so they've been renamed as Finra.
Okay.
These are all these institutional details.
I want you to know because it,
it's, it's boring maybe, but I think
it's what's true. It's what's happening.
This is what drives so much that happens.
So Thinra says that if you want
to become a financial advisor,
you have to pass a series.
They call it series 65 or 66 exam and
then you are eligible according to Finra.
Uh,
it,
Finra is an example of a s a
self regulatory organization.
The government in the United States
doesn't want to be making all the rules.
So they allow industry groups to form
their own self policing organizations.
Uh,
and so Finra is the Organization for
financial advisors and that is a,
an SRO and the SEC
accepts their licensing.
So that's what you have to do to
become a financial advisor. Uh,
you have to take these exams, join
Finra, then you go to the sec,
and then you register as
a financial advisor. Um,
and so the exams would warn you
about all kinds of bad practices. Uh,
for example,
uh,
about churning a portfolio.
I just mentioned what they did,
but repeat it.
That's when you call the guy
up every day and you say,
I just got a hot new idea for you.
Of course, yesterday you bought,
you bought Microsoft, Oh,
sell that, move to this. Uh,
and they just keep calling you
up. And that's, that's, uh,
it's a way to get licensed if you,
if you're,
if you are caught doing that because
it can't work if you trade every day,
there's no,
it's virtually impossible to make money
because the commissions will eat you
alive and less, you know, you know,
these guys who are attorney or fakes
because they can't be getting a new idea
every day. So that's
the kind of thing. Now,
financial planners are,
um, are a little different.
Uh, they, uh,
the designation of financial
planner is not regulated directly,
but we do have, is self
regulatory association. Uh, that,
uh, manage manages them. Uh,
so,
uh,
we have the financial
planning association,
that's their website. Uh, but uh,
fpa.org, uh, and they,
uh, license where they provide their
own designation. This is how it works.
Uh, in the u s particularly, uh, they,
they will,
uh,
certify someone as a certified financial
planner and FPA will require that every
financial planner first become
a financial advisor. Uh,
so that's,
uh,
this is a big organization that
incidentally, if anyone ever asks you,
I need investment advice.
Where do I get it? Uh,
it might be a good idea to direct them
to that website because they'll help you
get a financial planner,
which is more than a broker is supposed
to actually be planning for your life.
And that that's the essential
economic problem that we faced.
A stock brokers will often this,
it comes back to what a Henry
Paulson said in his proposal for rec
reorganization of our financial markets.
He thought,
and I think this may reflect
some essential wisdom,
that we should have
objectives based regulation.
Each organization should
be focused on an objective.
I think the objective of the
organization affects what you do.
So if you are a stock broker and if you
present yourself as someone who will buy
and sell stocks for you,
you're probably not going to get into
financial planning with your clients.
But if it's, if it's on your title, if
you're, you write this after your name,
your John Doe CFP,
then it says planner in your title.
I think that affects what you do.
And it helped.
What financial planners do is they say,
let's sit down and think about
your life goals and you know,
do you expect to have children, are
you going to send them to college? Uh,
and you know, this kind of thought,
which is very important. Um,
there's another one called
isn't for financial advisors,
napfa.org National Association
of Personal Financial Advisors.
And if someone asks you a,
where should I go for advice,
this is another good website
to go to because, uh,
what I like about nafa.org is that
they have all of their advisors sign a
statement that they will be fee only
advisors and they will never steer someone
towards an investment that provides a
kickback to them that that's a problem.
Is that often a financial advisor,
uh,
we'll be really trying to make money
selling you things that, uh, provides,
uh, um, money. They're not unbiased,
but NAPFA,
uh,
it's part of their code of ethics that
they're completely separate from any,
uh,
any organization.
They're pure financial advisers and
they don't make money from commissions.
It's only from the hourly
fee. So anywhere. What else?
So that's basically what I was going
to say about, um, financial advisors.
Uh, it's a big industry
and it's important. Uh,
and actually in my new
book, uh, I have, I have no,
I shouldn't say I have no connection
to this industry whatsoever,
but I actually was, uh, uh,
ad saying that I think as a national
policy we should subsidize this industry.
I think people need more financial advice.
Uh,
most people are just not with it enough.
They're not getting the
basic wisdom, uh, that, uh,
and so I think if, if we need more
of this, we should subsidize it.
I was just in Mexico,
uh, or over the weekend,
and I had the opportunity to meet the
president of Mexico, which was exciting.
And I,
I also heard him say that he thinks
Mexico needs more development of financial
culture.
And this seems to be the thing that
not enough Mexicans are really used to
dealing with sophisticated
financial institutions.
And so that's where we have to go
with Mexico. But I was saying, well,
it's just the same in every country.
I think there's a problem.
So, uh, uh,
but the other thing, so
that's, I won't say more about
financial advisors, but, uh,
uh,
let's move now to,
the other way that happens is
that people will turn over there.
Uh, uh, actually I'm going to
come back to trust and then later,
but the other,
the really big industry that manages
people's financial problems for them,
our institutional investors,
and these are groups that, uh,
organizations that pool
money for many people and uh,
invest the portfolio for them.
Uh,
and I wanted to start by
emphasizing how important they are.
Uh,
and I wanted to just present you with
the balance sheet for households and
nonprofits, uh, as, uh,
and just get some idea of how
important institutional investors are.
They're more important than
these financial advisors
because most of people's
wealth is really managed by institutions.
You don't have to ask any questions,
you don't have to do anything.
It's all done for you. Uh, so, uh,
just to, um, I wanted to
show the balance sheet
okay.
Of households
and nonprofits,
and that's table be 100 of
the flow of funds account.
This is for the United States,
but I think it would be
similar in other countries. Um,
and uh,
so we have assets on one side and
we have liabilities on another.
So we'll have assets and
then we'll have liabilities.
You might wonder, why do we put
households and nonprofits together?
It's really because there are three
types of persons that own things.
There's individuals are natural persons,
there are nonprofit organizations which
are like individuals because nobody owns
them.
They own themselves.
They're like people in
contrast to corporations that
are owned by individuals.
And then we also have the
government is the third.
So this is the non government balance
sheet. And so it's just about everything,
uh, in this country. And
I just wanted to review,
this is from the Federal Reserve and these
are estimates of course in subject to
error,
but uh,
and this is for 2007 fourth quarter,
which is the latest data.
Okay.
So assets are things that people own
and liabilities are things that people,
oh,
okay.
And your net worth is your assets
minus your liabilities. Um,
so let's start with assets. What
do you, I won't ask you to guess.
Uh,
the biggest asset that people own Indian
and I did state that households own is,
and nonprofits, this is almost
entirely households are nonprofits.
I small compared to household.
Real estate is the biggest thing.
And that is 22, uh, four,
eight,
$3 billion or $22 trillion.
Uh, and people own this
directly. It's their house.
But the second most,
the second biggest thing is pension funds.
And that is a
12 billion.
I mean it's 12 trillion,
12 billion,
twelve thousand seven hundred
and seventy nine billion. Okay.
So that comes after right
after real estate. Uh,
then we have equity in
non corporate business.
That is, um, seven, three, eight,
nine. I'm sorry, I'm reading
the wrong line. Seven, eight,
nine to almost 8 billion.
What, what is non corporate business?
It's business is run by individuals,
so it's like the low, you know, if a
family runs a little grocery store, uh,
then their ownership of
that is represented here
as non corporate business.
Or if you, if you're a barber and
you've got your little barbershop, um,
it all adds up.
They valued all of these businesses and
they valued them up totally as worth $8
trillion.
Uh,
and that we have corporate equities
that's star. Uh, and, and uh,
that is five, four, four,
7 billion or about 5 trillion.
Um, that's stocks owned
directly by household. Uh,
and then, uh, we have mutual funds.
Okay.
And mutual funds are institutional
investors that invest in stocks or bonds.
Uh,
but usually it's mostly stocks
five oh eight to a trillion.
So it's almost as big as corporate
equities hell directly. Um,
and then there's consumer durables.
That means your car, your furniture. Uh,
that's four oh eight,
I'm sorry,
four oh three 5 billion,
uh,
bonds.
I'm running out of room
here to seven. Three. Oh,
not so much. Not as big a insurance. Um,
I have everything ranked by size,
so we're going down the scale.
Insurance is, um, this is life
insurance one, two oh five.
Um, and then I'm running out
of room at the bottom of this.
There's some other minor
categories, uh, but the is,
I'll write it up here and since I
would normally put it at the bottom,
but I've out of room with the bottom.
The total assets total
is 72
oh nine, $3 billion. So $72 trillion
liabilities of households.
Um,
our mortgages,
home mortgages,
and that's 10,
five or nine.
Um,
consumer credit,
that's a credit cards,
installment credit, various
types, two, five, five,
1 billion, uh, loans
and other
one,
three,
one 5 billion.
And the tall and the total liabilities is,
um,
three one five.
So people own 72 trillion.
They owe 14 trillion.
The difference is net worth,
uh, is um, uh, 57,
seven one 8 billion.
So that's about $192,000 per
person in the United States.
It's unequally how light.
This is just consolidating everybody.
It's unequally held, uh, because, uh,
uh, rich people are more
this than poor people.
But in the average family
of four has about 800,000.
I'm just multiplying by 192,000 by four.
So we have a lot of wealth,
but the point here is what form is it in?
But real estate is very unmanaged.
People own their own homes, uh,
and there's not much institutional
involvement except through the mortgage.
Not that they owe about half.
They only own about half of their home.
The average person,
oh, is on the mortgage,
almost half the value of the home.
Okay.
So if you took net worth in
real estate, it would be, uh,
only like 12 trillion, right?
Assets minus real estate liability.
So by that account,
the biggest asset that people have
is apparently their pension fund.
Uh, that's huge. And that
is institutional investors.
The thing I wanted to make,
the point I wanted to make about this
is that institutional investors dominate
just about everything. I mean, you've got
real estate and non corporate business,
which are not easily managed by
institutional investors. Beyond that, uh,
it's mostly institutional
mutual funds,
well, and insurance. So, uh, we,
we live in a country
where things are done,
are managed by a professional investors.
Uh,
so maybe I'll just start on this board.
so, uh, so let's just talk about
a mutual. What does a mutual fund,
a mutual fund refers to a
structure of an investment company.
Uh, they're much more
important than hedge funds.
Hedge funds are,
we talked about those before,
are designed for a small
group of wealthy investors.
Mutual funds are for the general public,
uh,
and the reason they're called mutual is
that the fund is owned by the investors.
In it. Uh, and, uh,
the first mutual fund
was called Mit,
uh, no connection with Massachusetts
Institute of Technology.
This was the Massachusetts
Investors Trust, uh,
in the 1920s.
Uh,
and at that time there were
a lot of investor funds,
uh, that were not
relatively unregulated. Uh,
and they were offering investments
to people that were, uh,
oversold often and often.
Uh,
there were classes of
shareholders. There was a, uh, uh,
class of prime shareholders who got
the profits from the enterprise.
And then there was a class of other
shareholders who were the Hoi Polloi who,
um,
and after 1929,
many of the investment funds crashed
and burned and people got very upset.
They were very upset,
particularly that the investment fund
was really being run for the profit and
benefit of the guys who started the fund,
not all the people who were in there.
And so after 1929,
there was looking around is how should
the investment funds really be organized.
And then attention became focused on
MIT because it was an honest fund.
Uh, and they thought this
should be the model for, uh,
our investment fund industry.
But what Massachusetts Investment
Trust did is they said,
everybody is equal and we're
completely open about what we do.
We publish our portfolio.
Uh,
and most investment funds were
secret. They were saying, well,
we're going to beat the market. We're
not going to publish what we're doing.
The Mit published its portfolio.
It had only one class of investors.
In fact, the fund was owned by
the investors. It's a mutual fund.
So if you put money in, you join
the crowd, we invest for you.
Uh,
and if you want to take your money out,
we'll share your proportion of the
whole portfolio. That was the concept.
So the concept, uh, became very, uh,
widely respected and
the whole industry grew.
The Investment Act of 1940,
uh,
the Investment Company act,
1940,
it doesn't actually define mutual funds,
but it defines structures that are
used by mutual funds. And so after, uh,
after the Investment Company
act, uh, starting in the 1950s,
mutual funds began to grow
and grow. Uh, and, um,
uh,
they are regulated in such a way that,
uh, the, as I've said, all,
everyone is equal in the fund.
Everyone benefits from the portfolio
in an, uh, in an equal way.
And the rule is that if you don't buy
and sell shares in the Mutual Fund,
this fund owns shares.
You're putting money into the fund and
if you want to get money out of the fund,
you call him up for,
or maybe you can do it on the web and you,
you say you place an order to
withdraw money from the fund.
And what they will do when you withdraw
money is they wait until 4:00 PM,
uh, on the day of your
order. Uh, and then, uh,
they calculate what your share of the
fund would be based on 4:00 PM is when the
stock market's closed.
Uh, and so at 4:00 PM,
you would get out at those prices.
Uh,
and that was considered a fair
and honest thing, uh, to do.
They don't charge high management fees.
Uh,
there's rules about that. Uh, and so, um,
uh, they have their own Srr, uh,
called ICI a investment company institute
that was created I believe in the
1940s. So this has become the structure
for the way most people, well, I,
half people, most small investors do
not own corporate equity directly.
They own mutual funds.
Uh,
there have been some scandals
about mutual fund, um,
that emerge in the last decade or so.
My spirit scandals, uh, there's
something called late training.
What was happening is,
uh,
sometimes there's mutual funds didn't
enforce the rules well enough. Uh,
you would, you would tell your broker, uh,
I'd like to withdraw money from the
mutual fund and the broker would then
sometimes call, um, after 4:00 PM and say,
uh,
my client really asked me to sell
this at 10:00 AM this morning.
I know it's 5:00 PM, but you know,
trust me, I'd like to get out.
Uh, and mutual funds would let this
happen. Then it turned out to be abused.
Why is that abusive?
If you're a mutual fund,
then you get this call from
my broker saying, trust me,
my client asked me to get out
at 10:00 AM I know it's five.
Can we get out? Uh, well,
that turns out to be a bad practice
because what ended up happening is people
are abused.
That they would wait until five or 6:00
PM and they would observe what seems to
be happening in the markets.
And if it's going up,
then they would say we wanted to
put money into the mutual fund.
And if it's going down,
they would say,
we're trying to take money out of
the mutual fund. You see how that,
that hurts the other mutual fund
investors because you do it strategically.
You do. If you know the market
is up, you're trading on,
on steel prices and old prices, obviously
you can make money doing that. Uh,
and this got a lot of attention in
the newspaper, the late trading. Um,
and uh,
uh,
there was another, uh, another
variation on that called market timing,
but it's basically the same
thing where a mutual funds,
we're not enforcing the rules properly.
And so some people were trading at that
4:00 PM price effectively after it.
Uh, and so, um,
uh,
but, uh, they've cleaned up this act.
And so I think that a mutual funds,
our most trusted way of investing in
the stock market and most people won't
invest in individual stocks anymore.
Uh, they just go through mutual funds.
There is another kind of thing
that has developed more recently,
uh,
and it's called an exchange traded funds,
R, n e t. A.
And these were created first.
These are relatively new.
Uh,
these were created first at
the American Stock Exchange
and 1993.
Uh,
and they're different from a mutual fund.
I did was show them separately on
this. They're much smaller, uh,
then mutual funds, I believe they're
less than a trillion dollars.
They must be in one of these other
categories up there. But, um,
exchange traded funds are different than
a mutual fund in that they are traded
on a stock exchange. Uh,
and so the first, uh,
uh,
the first exchange traded fund
with a company called a spider,
that's standard in toward
depositary receipt.
But now there is a proliferation
of, of uh, exchange traded funds.
So what is an exchange traded fund? I
said, this is louder than you hear me.
All right, right. Uh, uh,
exchange traded fund, uh, is uh,
as epitomized by the,
this is the s and p 500.
It's a port folio that is
managed according to rules.
It's not judgmental. Uh, and uh,
you cannot call up the exchange traded
fund and say, I want my money back.
It's different from a mutual fund.
If you get in,
you would buy or sell an exchange
traded fund on the Stock Exchange.
Uh, and so the uh, uh,
the fund is traded on the exchange
traded fund holds a portfolio.
I like the spider holds the portfolio
equivalent to the s and p 500.
Uh, and they pay out dividends
on that. But in the meantime, uh,
you can buy or sell shares in
the fund on the Stock Exchange.
They also have what are
called creation units,
uh, which are, uh,
in large denominations
like millions of dollars.
And institutional investors can either
create or redeem shares in the ETFs,
but you as an individual cannot.
All right.
So if the creation unit is $1 million,
then an institutional investor who is
an authorized participant and it has
signed the right papers, you can
say, can you go to the AMX and say,
I want to create a $10
million of new spiders.
And then the Amex, we'll say, that's
10 creation units. I'm saying, I don't,
I forget what it spiders creation unit is,
but let's say it's $1 million.
Then the AMX would say,
all right,
you have to give us the
stocks in the s and p 500, uh,
in the proportion that they are in
the s and p 500 equal in value to $10
million. Uh, and that becomes, uh,
uh, one creation and then they'll give
the institutional investors the shares to
sell.
Conversely,
the institutional investor can go to the
AMX and say, I want to go the other way.
I've got a 10,000 shares of these ETFs,
I want,
I want this stocks back.
So the institutional investor can present
the shares to the AMX and AMX will
then give them the shares
in the s and p 500.
That enforces the price of the ETF equal
to the price of the underlying stocks.
So ETFs were designed so that the price
of the ETF tracks tracks the price of
the underlying stocks,
uh,
in contrast to things
called close down funds, uh,
which are similar, but they don't
have the creation units closed down.
The funds,
the price of the fun and the stock market
tends to go through either a premium
or a discount depending on the market,
but ETFs tend to track well.
That is the price of the unit.
TF,
uh, tends to correspond to the
price of the underlying stocks,
whereas close a closed end.
Mutual funds,
I say close down funds track poorly.
And so ETFs is the new
thing, uh, that, uh,
uh,
that has developed.
I said, I would talk about, uh,
personal trusts, uh, and I thought, oh,
this is something that, um, uh, is,
um, I've less, somewhat less important,
but it's about a trillion dollars
in our modern economy. Uh,
so what is a trust is another
form of institutional investing.
Ah,
okay.
Trust is a, uh, uh, it's often, uh,
the department of a
bank that manages money,
uh, on behalf of a, uh,
uh,
of a individual or family.
Uh, and, uh, for example,
suppose a,
your parents are concerned about
you and they don't trust you.
They trust the banker, not you. Uh,
and there's a family fortune. Uh,
maybe it doesn't have to be that big,
but let's say it's $1 million. Uh,
they could give it to you.
Uh, but they might not,
I don't know about your parents are doing,
they're doing this behind your back,
maybe not telling you in
great detail. Uh, but, uh,
a particular importance as an example
of something called a spendthrift
trust.
I'm not spelling it right.
T h.
R.
Okay.
Well what does a spend thrift and someone
who can't save money and squanders it.
So your parents can go to a bank and set
up a spend thrift trust on your behalf
and the spend trust will then
pay you an income for life.
Or they could even go beyond your life.
They could go to your children
or whatever, uh, but, uh,
that prevents you from squandering
the money from going to the casino and
gambling it away. If your parents
don't trust you, uh, and so, uh,
you see the idea of the bank,
then we'll manage it for the rest
of your life and your parents will,
will die and you'll outlive him.
But that money will be stuck in that trust
and you can't get it out because they
set it up and it's there.
Uh, and so, uh, uh, then,
uh,
the manager of the trust is a fiduciary
who is by a contract is supposed to be
managing in the interest of the
child, the spendthrift child. Uh,
and, uh, of course everyone, all these
people will be dead before you are.
Your parents will die.
The first thing they talk to at the bank,
setting up the trust and will die.
Uh, but when you're 90 years old,
there'll be someone at that bank
person is much younger than you who was
appointed in succession to manage your
trust and will continue to pay you that
income out of your trust.
Now,
if there's another reason why your
parents might be doing this, uh,
which he might not, you might be angry
with your parents if they did this right?
Uh,
but they might do it for another reason,
and that is you could get
married and get a divorce. Okay?
And they're worried about this.
A really awful person you married taking
half of the family money when you get
divorced, right? So they lock it
up in a spend thrift trust. Uh,
and then after the divorce, the trustee
will say, no way, I'm, you know,
I'm bound to pay this person,
not the wife or husband,
the amount of money for life.
And it apparently works.
So that's another reason why families,
we'll do this because they don't want to
give them money to the awful person you
married. Uh, uh, so, uh,
in common law countries,
trusts are,
that's like the u s in the UK.
Uh,
trust are well defined in law and
a trustee has well defined rights.
Uh, if you are, and it doesn't
have to be a bank, we allow, uh,
you can have a friend of yours become
a trustee. Uh, in common law countries.
There's a nice segregation of the,
uh,
assets in the trust and
the assets of the trustee.
So suppose you ask your brother-in-law
to serve as a trustee for your children
and then your brother in law gets into
some bad financial situation and goes
bankrupt.
Courts will not be allowed to take the
trust that the brother-in-law is managing
for your children.
Okay.
This wasn't so clear in a civil
law countries such as in Europe,
the typical trust in Europe has
been that you would go to a,
and the bank would manage the trust
for you, but if the bank went under,
you might lose the money. Uh, and uh,
maybe there's more trusting
of their banks in Europe.
I think this is also changing.
The law is always changing.
Um, okay, now I wanted
to come to pension funds,
which are,
uh,
the most important kind of,
institutional. You can see up
there that the $12 trillion,
it doesn't include, this pension fund
here does not include social security,
which is of comparable magnitude.
The government runs its own pension fund
in effect called the social security
system. And that's not shown here. So, uh,
there's a lot of pension funds are private
funds managing a portfolio of assets.
The social security system does not
manage a substantial portfolio of assets.
Uh, the social security system,
which is a, it's not on here,
I'm just mentioning it as an aside.
We set up by US Congress in
1935 to provide for the elderly,
uh, and also for a disabled and uh, um,
orphan children.
But this main social security
provides for the elderly, but it does.
So without investing it,
there is something called the Social
Security Trust Fund managed by the
government,
which invests in assets to help the
government pay out on social security.
However,
the Social Security Trust Fund is only
last time I heard about $1 trillion.
So the government is not
investing much compared to, uh,
these pension funds.
The pension funds are much bigger.
And these are our agencies,
private agencies that invest,
uh,
on behalf of people for their retirement.
Uh,
and they are very important
element of our economy.
They help us solve the essential problem
that everyone goes through the life
cycle. You're young, you're healthy
for a while, you're working,
and then your health starts to deteriorate
and then you have years or decades
when you are either not
inclined to work or cannot work.
Uh, and this happens with such
regularity that, uh, it, it, uh,
requires some kind of
professional management and
that's what pension funds do.
So I wanted to talk about these
in some more detail. The, the,
uh, it wasn't until the 19th
century that we had them,
which is kind of surprising because
it's such an important problem.
And even in the 19th century, they
were few and rare. Uh, but, um,
the, uh, the first us, I think they go,
they go back earlier in the UK
and in places in Europe. But,
uh,
in the United States,
the first corporate pension funds
was American Express in 1875.
American Express then was not a
credit card company. It was a,
it was a shipping company
or a transportation company.
Uh,
and uh,
it's first a pension fund was for the,
was for the employees of American Express.
Uh,
and the original terms where you had to
work there for 20 years and past the age
of 60, and you had also
to be disabled. Uh,
and if you satisfied though,
if you were over 60,
you had worked at American Express
for 20 years and also were disabled,
uh,
you would get 50% of the average pay
for the last 10 years you worked there.
This is the earliest model in the u s
uh, and that, uh, gradually they
became copied by more companies.
Uh, it became more and
more important as the 19th.
And we moved into the 20th century
because life expectancy was going up.
There were relatively few people with
the life expectancy at 1900 was something
like 45 years.
I don't have the exact number.
So 60 was a milestone that a lot of people
didn't reach. Oh, of course. Others,
many did as well. So it's not a,
this was important even
then, but, uh, it wasn't,
the original pension funds tended to be
done for the benefit of the employer in
the sense that like the American Express,
you had to work there for all of 20
years, uh, in order to get anything.
It was all or nothing. If you
work there for 19 years, uh,
then too bad and you've got nothing.
It didn't seem well designed,
but it was designed to keep people there.
They didn't want people leaving.
And so once he signed
onto American Express,
you were kind of stuck there because
you didn't want to get out, uh,
you'd lose your pension. Um, so, uh,
the, uh, it wasn't very big, but, uh, uh,
big institution in the
Carnegie Steel Pension,
a pension plan was 1901.
Andrew Carnegie,
uh, which was a milestone
because it started to, uh,
establish the principle on there.
This was the first big company
to establish a pension fund. Uh,
and it grew through the first
few decades of the 19th century.
Uh, and by 1929, there were
many pension funds. Uh,
they started doing union pension funds.
So there were the cigar makers,
uh,
that was a union,
um,
or granite cutters and
cigar makers in 1905, uh,
locomotive engineers,
that was 19, 12. Uh,
many of these funds failed in 1929
and they were offered by companies
for their employees or unions,
uh, for their members. Uh,
when companies offered
tensions for their employees,
that was a risky thing because companies
go bankrupt. It happens all the time.
And if they go bankrupt, how are they
going to pay the pension plan? Well,
that was tough luck for the employee.
He's, that was a lesson enlightened time.
They didn't,
the point was that they rarely funded
the pension funds in the early decades of
the 20th century.
Carnegie steel just ran about Carney,
but generally they just promised to pay.
They just said,
we will pay you when you retire.
And out of what you might ask, well,
that wasn't explained,
but it had to be out of profits.
And what if they weren't making
any profits? Well, they didn't ask.
People didn't seem to
anticipate this. After 1929, uh,
these, these, um,
pension funds became discredited
because so many of them failed.
Uh, and that led to, uh, a,
a idea that we had to
do something different.
So,
uh,
the big milestone in pension history
is the General Motors Pension Fund,
uh, which, uh,
g m pension,
which was created in 1950.
Uh, and, uh, it was, uh,
promoted by GM chairman Charles Wilson.
Uh,
I visited them recently.
They were in that building
right across the street,
what is the Plaza Hotel at the
corner of central park. Um,
and they're, uh, a very
big organization now,
but the thing that GM pension
fund did is it, it invested,
it funded.
And so they started investing money on
behalf of the pensioners so that if GM
were to ever go bankrupt, they would
still be money in the fund. Uh,
and not GM stock.
This was the most amazing thing.
The people that Ge General Motors was
investing money for its pension fund and
of all things, it wasn't buying
GM stock. Seville thought,
why wouldn't they buy their own stock?
They would push the price up,
but of course it's not enlightened to
buy their own stock because that would be
stupid to invest the pension fund in
your own stock because the stock would
become worthless in the same circumstance
that you would be unable to make good
on the pension. So it wouldn't
do any good. So it was odd.
It seemed obvious that companies should
fund their pension funds and should
invest in something other than
their own stock. Uh, and so,
uh, uh, that may seem obvious,
but it took until 1950.
One thing that strikes me about financial
history is that it seems like we go
for such a long time doing things
that are obviously not right.
Uh, and as long as there is no
crisis, nobody pays attention to it.
Then we have this huge crisis,
like the 1929 stock market crash,
and then it's an only an after the
crisis that anyone thinks about it.
So I don't know what was happening for
the first 30 years of the 20th century.
They had all these pension funds, but the
whole idea seemed to be faulty. Right.
Why would you think that your company
can support you in your old age?
That's decades in the future.
You know,
the chance that your company would go
under. It has to be substantial. Uh,
but you know,
people don't seem to see these risks
and they don't think about them until
there's a big crisis.
That's where I think that we are at an
opportune time right now with another
financial crisis.
And it's a time when people might be
willing to think about how to do things
differently. Um, so, uh,
the next big crisis in pension fund
history was the Studebaker default.
1963.
Have you ever heard of Studebaker?
No. You were heard of them. They are
made cars. They were one of the big,
and how many car makers in
the fifties and sixties?
Uh,
you probably still see these on the road,
but they're getting quite rare
because that's 45 years ago. Uh,
they were big for a while. Uh, anyway,
they, the company went bankrupt,
uh, in 1963. And, uh,
now they claimed to have
funded a pension plan.
They were learning from GM and they
were investing a pension plan or their
employees in assets that should have
survived the bankruptcy. So they thought,
uh,
but uh,
after the bankruptcy it found out that
they had underfunded the pension plan.
Okay.
That means that they didn't put enough
money to pay what they promised to pay so
that while they had it, they just
didn't, they didn't put enough in.
So then people started getting angry.
Obviously people at work,
their lives at Studebaker promised that
they were told that they had a funded
pension fund and when they went there,
they found that they got nothing
or at least very much reduced.
So people started looking at the union,
the United autoworkers.
Isn't the United auto workers supposed
to stand up for the rights of the men,
the employees,
and shouldn't they be looking at the
pension fund and demanding that Studebaker
funded adequately? Well, they were,
they were asleep. They were not,
they were asleep at the switch or some
people accused the UAW of complicity with
Studebaker,
that basically the UAW was not paying
attention to the distant future because
they didn't think that
their members really cared.
So you UAW wanted it when they
had negotiations with Studebaker,
they wanted big pay increases.
Now they didn't care about funding the
pension fund. Why didn't they care? Well,
because the workers at Studebaker
didn't know or understand this.
And so the workers were
not attuned to this.
So the union thrives on getting something
that looks valuable to the employees,
but the employees were being deceived so
that both Studebaker and the union were
in it together against
the employees in a sense.
So this created a lot of
them anger, uh, about,
about failures of pension funds.
Uh,
I'm talking about financial
crises of years past. Uh,
we're going through a
subprime crisis right now. Uh,
and this is one of a series.
Every time we have a financial crisis,
we make fixes. And so in reaction to
the Studebaker it took, took 10 years,
but the Studebaker default set in law
enforce a dialogue about how pension
should be managed. And that led to, uh,
Arista, uh, 1974,
actually 11 years later.
And, uh, Rissa, uh,
stands for employment,
retirement income security
act, all right. Employment,
retirement income
Security Act, uh, and, uh,
it then required funding.
So it required a
adequate funding.
You know,
Studebaker had a funded pension
plan, but it was under, uh,
underfunded.
So that's what Rissa created.
Um, and, uh, they also created, uh, the,
uh,
pension benefits guaranty corporation.
PBGC this is a government,
uh, core, well, it's,
it's a government sponsored
enterprise that, uh,
uh, insurers, so pension benefit
guarantee corp
the deal is, it's likely federal
deposit Insurance Corporation,
which guarantees your bank deposit.
It guarantees ear pension plan.
So the PBGC then receives dues from a
pension plans and the pension plans.
Then if they were to fail, uh, would get,
uh,
the pensioneers would get
a payment from the PBGC.
All right.
So the PBGC is supposed to monitor
the funds of pension plans,
make sure that they're
adequately funded, and then, uh,
if they are not adequately funded,
then
they would make up the
difference. Uh, now,
ultimately the PBGC has a portfolio of
assets which it accumulates from the fees
paid to it by the pension funds.
Uh,
that portfolio of assets might
not be adequate in a huge crisis.
Uh,
and so congress might have to
step in to support the PBGC.
Otherwise the PBGC is not
taking taxpayers' money.
Recently the PBGC has come under some
attack because after the stock market,
it's very hard to know whether a pension
fund is adequately funded or not. Right?
Because it all depends on
assumptions about asset prices.
During the run up of stock
market in the 1990s, uh,
for firms started cutting back on
the amount they contributed to their
retirement funds because the,
the stock market had made them,
had made their plans look
very rich. Uh, and so, uh,
there are people like me claiming that it
was a bubble and that, so the price is,
we're not going to stay at this level,
but it's kind of hard to
make that prove that point.
So companies in the late nineties,
uh,
were not,
they were putting their
money in risky stocks and,
and saying they were adequately funded.
Uh,
when there were people like
me who are doubting that,
and the PBGC being a government
organization didn't protest.
I, after the stock market
came down after 2000,
it put the PBGC and jeopardy.
Fortunately,
the market went back up again and
kind of avail them out. But, uh,
uh,
the Erisa act also embodied something
called the prudent person rule.
Actually in 1974,
they called it the prudent man rule.
Uh,
that was because 74 was just before
we tried to use nonsexist language.
So the prudent man rule
is now the prudent person.
But I'll read what the Arista
said. The act said, um,
investments must be made with the care,
skill,
prudence and diligence
under the circumstances.
Then prevailing that a prudent man acting
in a light capacity and familiar with
such matters would use in the conduct
of an enterprise of a light character.
And with like ames, well that's lawyer
ease, but basically what they're saying,
the fundamental problem is that even
if you get beyond the deliberate
underfunding of a pension plan,
you still get the possibility that the
pension managers will do something wild
like put everything in the stock market.
Or they could put leverage investments
in the stock market and they could say
we're funded enough because with
this huge, hugely leverage portfolio,
we should have enough money, but
that wouldn't be prudent. Right?
And so if the government is guaranteeing
pension plans as they're going, as they,
they started doing with the PBGC,
then they've got to prevent that.
Uh, and so because they can't let
companies just do wild investments.
But this put the government in a funny
circumstance because it was Darren to
tell these funds that they,
that they had to be doing sensible
investing. But what is sensible investing?
It actually,
it was a difficult thing to define.
Look at Yale University back in 19,
when David Swensen came to Yale,
most universities put
their money in sensible,
safe government bonds and
stocks were considered risky,
but Swenson said, no, let's not do that.
Let's put into these strange alternative
investments. And after the fact,
he turns out to be right.
Right. Was he not prudent?
Do you want to tell investment companies
that they shouldn't do that? It's a,
it's a difficult question.
And the question is,
how far should it be pension plan go
in taking on risk risky investments.
So the law created the strange,
prudent person rule,
which says that an investment company
should do whatever a prudent person would
do.
Um,
and I created an unfortunate
environment for pension fund management.
Basically they're telling pension fund
managers do, don't use your own judgment.
Do what somebody else would do.
And you manage the portfolio. Uh,
right. I mean, that's law. I
mean, you've got to do this.
It's in the law as a
manager. Uh, and so, uh, uh,
it's a, it's a slippery business
to be in. So, um, I have on the,
it's actually, I don't expect you to
go to read this because it's, it's,
it should be in the library,
but Obar and commonly, uh,
wondered how tension funds deal with
this strange situation they're put in.
Uh,
so this is oh,
Var and calmly work. One of these, uh,
is an anthropologist. So we're getting
a little bit of insight from it.
I mentioned I like to take insights
from all the different social sciences.
Anthropologists like to go into some
primitive village somewhere in the world
and interview people,
uh,
who live in a very different
culture and try to learn about them.
And what an anthropologist does.
It goes into some village, uh, and,
uh, it doesn't disturb their,
tries not to disturb their culture,
doesn't start explaining things,
just listens and tries to understand
how they think it has to learn their
language and listened to their,
and presumably to get insights
about human behavior, uh,
from the experience of immersing
oneself in some other culture.
Uh, so, uh,
these people went to interview a pension
fund managers with the same techniques
that anthropologists use
in a primitive villages.
Uh, and, uh, they concluded, uh, that,
uh, pension funds, uh,
are there, uh, there, there are
rather critical of pension funds.
The pension funds are living in this
strange world created by Arista,
which requires that they
behave as somebody else would.
And so it kind of separates them
from any real sense of their mission.
They're regulated so heavily.
Uh,
and so what Obara unkindly found is
that they engage people in discussion.
They listened to what managers
have pension funds would
say on their own without
suggesting that topic of conversation.
And what they found was that managers,
uh,
we're very much aware of
the prudent person rule, uh,
and that they were always looking
to shift blame, possible blame.
They're always thinking of some lawsuit
that they could eventually be embroiled
in. And they, they're always saying, well,
this is what a prudent person would do.
They talk a lot about the law and
relatively little about economics or,
uh,
or the objectives that they're supposed
to have about how do we get to,
uh,
the management of a,
how do we manage this portfolio to provide
for the benefits to our employees in
the future? Uh, and, uh,
it's interesting that as anthropologists,
they took note of what anthropologists
have noted in many primitive societies,
that if you let people living
in some isolated culture talk,
they tend to come up eventually
with a creation myth.
Okay. So this is the term
the anthropologist, every
primitive society. We can,
you can ask them where did it
all start? Right. And they would,
they will generally have a story about
the creation of their little village or
their people,
uh,
which involves some great man or God that,
founded everything. Uh, and there
some story about this person,
uh, and, uh, a sense that we are
the chosen people that were the, uh,
we have some values are,
and it's built around a story of
some great man or woman, I suppose.
Uh, but, uh, uh,
what they said is that that's one of
the things they heard most commonly,
the creation myth.
So they would say are a pension fund
was started by so and so 40 years ago.
And this person had great insights and
we're living in this tradition ever since.
Uh, so, um, but, uh, so,
uh,
so, uh, anyway, uh,
Rissa came in at more or less
the end of an era. There's,
there are really two
kinds of pension plans.
There is a defined benefit
and defined contribution.
There's a fundamental difference.
A defined benefit pension plan
tells you that the pension,
we'll pay you a certain amount.
For example,
I mentioned the very first us
pension from American Express.
It promised to pay you 50% of your
average pay for the last 10 years that you
were employed. Okay. So
you were told this, uh,
when you started the job
that this was your plan. Uh,
and so that define the benefit.
You would get a,
until 1974,
virtually all pension plans
were defined benefit. Uh,
there were some exceptions,
but it was the overwhelming norm.
Labor unions liked defined benefit, it
sounded right to them. But the, the,
the contrary,
the Chi is called defined contribution
in a defined contribution plan.
The pension plan does not promise you
anything about what your retirement income
will be. They merely say that
we are going to contribute your,
a fraction of your salary,
uh,
to a portfolio that will be managed
to provide you income when you retire.
But the amount you get will be
determined by the portfolio and not by,
uh, any arbitrary rule.
There's nothing like, you know,
50% of the last 10 years of your income.
The defined contribution plans
got their biggest impetus in 1981.
So that's what,
seven years after a Rissa with the advent
of what was called four o one k plans,
four o one k is a paragraph in the
Internal Revenue Service Code Code.
That's the tax.
That's the IRS that the agency
of the government that taxes,
uh,
everyone and rule section
four o one k of the IRS code,
um,
uh,
defined circumstances in which,
money held in trust for others
might not be taxable. Uh,
and in 1981, uh, for the
first time a company,
uh,
invoked this clause to get asked that
the defined contribution plan that they
were setting up would not be text.
Uh,
the, uh, well actually what make it clear,
what it would be is if the employer or
employee made contributions to the plan,
then there would be no tax that would
be a tax deduction for the amount of the
contribution until later
after the person retires.
It would be taxed many years later as
ordinary income when they received it.
But by postponing the tax,
it was a significant tax advantage.
So after 1981, there was a
tremendous revolution in our tax,
in our pension system because,
uh,
it led, uh, first of all,
people like tax breaks and it sounds
good to get a tax break. But secondly,
um,
people start unions were declining unions,
which had always advocated
defined benefits were
declining as a force in the u s
and people were developing in the United
States more of an investment culture.
And they liked the idea that they would
have a defined contribution plan where
there would be a
portfolio which is theirs,
which is being invested for the retirement
rather than trust the company to
provide a benefit in retirement.
So the general public showed a strong
preference for defined contribution plans
after 1981.
And so that is a big force.
The U S was a leader in
defined contribution plans,
but it is now spreading
all over the world. Uh,
and I think it again reflects
the change in our world culture.
So they're growing in Europe and
uh, and other, I guess Mexico,
a Chili there.
There's so many of the pension plans
now are of the defined contribution
variety, even a government
pension plans. So the government,
social security planning Chile,
uh,
allows you invest for you.
Uh,
and if there's a portfolio
and you can get on a website,
I understand I've never done it in Chile,
but you can see what the
balances in your account.
Another thing that defined contribution
plans began to do with the advent of
401k is they would allow you as a
employee or as the pensioner to choose the
general categories of investments.
So they would,
they would typically in a defined
contribution plan, after 1981,
there will be a number of mutual funds
that you could invest your money in.
And now you couldn't take
it out until you retired.
You could choose which from a
selected list of mutual funds,
you could invest your money.
And so this helped promote
mutual funds dramatically. Uh,
and it also created more of an
investment culture in our society.
So, uh, so, uh, that's where we are now.
Uh, the defined benefit pension
plan is declining rapidly.
Ressa is, it's still not irrelevant
because they're still important,
but a Rissa is becoming less and less
important and we're moving on toward a
country. When you get your first job, the
first thing you will get, I can predict,
will be a four o one k plan. And, uh,
you will probably not be given a,
a defined benefit pension.